I'm happy to welcome you to the third of
this year's Terry lectures a lecturer
this year for those of you who've been
following these you these lectures you
know this already is Don Lopez the opera
link distinguished University professor
of Buddhist and Tibetan studies at the
University of Michigan his topic today
is the problem with Karma and this will
pick up the conversation he began last
week when he lectured to us on a
purified religion and building a better
Buddha in both of those lectures he
reviewed for us the modern construction
of Buddha and Buddhism in the modern
colonial period and noted how in the
West this construction was intimately
bound up with ideas modern ideas of
science presenting to us a challenge
about relating science and religion a
topic which came up rather repeatedly in
the conversations after the lectures we
look forward to today's lecture on karma
and continuing the conversation about
science and religion without further ado
then let me call on our distinguished
gem lecturer Don Lopez
Thank You Dean at region thanks to all
of you who were back for yet another
lecture it is the quest of 1911 Dwight
Terry asked lecturers be given quote on
ethics the history of civilization and
religion biblical research all Sciences
and branches of knowledge which have an
important bearing on the subject all the
great laws of nature especially of
evolution the last term in his list
should not surprise us for in the
decades about the relation in the
debates about the relation between
religion and science at the turn of the
century evolution was clearly a charged
topic and 100 years later the power of
Darwin's theory remains strong so strong
that at least in our country all manner
of state and local governments argue
often heatedly about whether evolution
should be taught to our children in
18-49 Alfred Lord Tennyson published in
memoriam
a work he'd originally entitled the way
of the soul it's a long work of 133
kantos ranging over many themes about
halfway through there is a famous lament
it's in the 56 canto where nature speaks
from scarpered cliff and quarried stone
she cries a thousand types are gone I
care for nothing all shall go they'll
make his thine appeal to me I bring to
life I bring to death the spirit does
but mean the breath I know no more and
he shall he-man her last work who seemed
so fair such splendid purpose in his
eyes who ruled the psalm to wintry skies
who built him veins of fruitless prayer
who trusted God was love indeed and
loved creations final law though nature
red in tooth and claw with Raven
shrieked against his Creed who loved who
suffered countless ills who battled for
the truth adjust
be blown about the desert dust or sealed
within the iron hills the section of in
memoriam was prompted not by Darwin on
the Origin of Species would not appear
for another decade but by Tennyson's
reading of a work called vestiges of the
natural history of creation published
anonymously in 1844 the author turned
out to be Robert Chambers a Scottish
journalist yet Tennyson expressed a fear
that has persisted from the Victorian
age into our own a fear that we are but
passing constituents of a material world
that we are but future fossils our hopes
and aspirations disappearing at our
death our virtue in vain our prayers
unanswered put into more modern language
we are dying machines designed for a
single purpose this revival of selfish
genes as I discussed in the last lecture
since the 19th century the Buddha has
been called upon to serve as an
alternative Savior and Buddhism as an
alternative religion thus since the 19th
century Buddhism has been portrayed as
their religion that is not at odds with
science indeed Buddhism is the one
religion that is compatible with science
that claim has extended to specific
scientific theories and the most
challenging theory of all for religion
the theory of evolution two fundamental
doctrines of Buddhism the doctrine of
karma and the attendant doctor rebirth
were seen Dan and continued to be seen
today as somehow analogous to the theory
of evolution
thus the leading British scholar of
Buddhism of Victorian period
Thomas W Reiss David's stated in the
Hibbert lectures of 1881 quote and the
more thoroughgoing the evolutionist the
more clear his vision of the long
perspective of history the greater will
be his appreciation of the strangeness
of the fact that a that a theory so far
consistent with what he holds to be true
should have been possible at all and so
remote a past we read in the front for
the Zeitung of April 25th 1890 quote in
itself
ISM is a profound an all-embracing
doctrine adapted particularly for our
time because it does not contradict
science but contains on the contrary the
germs of scientific truths for example
transform ism or Darwinism are involved
in Buddhism and finally Thomas Huxley
Darwin's bulldog himself wrote in 1894
quote like the doctrine of evolution
itself that of transmigration has it has
its roots in the world of reality and it
may claim such support as the great
argument from analogy is capable of
supplying I would add as a footnote that
much of the credit for the widespread
perception of a compatibility between
Darwin's theory of evolution and the
Buddhist doctrine rebirth
during this period should go to the
Theosophists the Theosophical society
founded in 1875 during the heyday of
spiritualism is largely dismissed today
but in the decades bracketing the turn
of the century it influenced it included
many influential thinkers and artists
both in America and in Europe some of
the first claim for the compatibility of
Buddhism and science came from its
founders the Russian emigre Helena
Petrovna Blavatsky and the Civil War
veteran Henry steel Olcott Madame
Blavatsky set forth her own theory of
rebirth in such works as the secret
doctrine published in 1888 according to
which entities that she called monads
evolved over millions of years in a
process of ascent through increasingly
advanced forms Blavatsky and her
followers would claim that this system
of spiritual evolution had already been
intimated in the ancient mystery
religions as well as in Buddhism the
theosophist Walter Evans Wentz observed
in his first book entitled the fairy
faith in Celtic countries published in
1911 that darwin's error was that he
never identified exactly what it is that
evolves it cannot be the physical body
since that dissolves at death so Evans
went wrote quote Darwin thus overlooked
the essential factor in his whole
doctrine while the Druids and other
ancients
wiser than we have been willing to admit
seem not only to him to have anticipated
Darwin by thousands of years but also to
have surpassed him and setting up their
doctrine of rebirth which explains both
the physical and cycle evolution
evolution of man
Evans whence would make this claim more
powerfully in his second book entitled
the Tibetan Book of the Dead today's
lecture I will take up the problem of
karma seeking to determine to what
extent if any it is compatible with the
theory of natural selection we will find
I think that like Christianity Buddhism
is not immune to the challenge of
Charles Darwin and I will take some
comfort in the fact that at least on
this point I'm not alone in calling the
compatibility of Buddhism and science
into question the current Dalai Lama has
recently expressed his his own concerns
on this point and I'm always happy to
have him on my side so let me begin with
a brief overview of the doctrine of
karma which is in a sense Buddhist
science the closest thing that Buddhism
has to a theory of everything in the mud
Jamuna kya the middle link discourses of
the Buddha we find the following
exchange a young Brahmin asked the wood
master Gautama what is the cause and
condition why human beings are seen to
be inferior and superior four people are
seen to be short lived and long lived
sickly and healthy ugly and beautiful
uninfluential and influential poor and
wealthy lowborn and highborn stupid and
wise what is the cause and condition
master Gautama why human beings are seen
to be inferior and superior the Buddha
replied student beings are owners of
their actions heirs of their actions
they originate from their actions have
their actions as their refuge it is
action that distinguishes beings has
inferior and superior and quote the word
translated here as action is of course
karma a Sanskrit term of pre-buddhist
origin but it's largely through Buddhism
that it has made its way into the
European lexicon
becoming the most widely used Buddhist
term in the English language more even
than Buddha more than nirvana in common
parlance karma functions as a Ruff's
synonym of fate or luck often bad luck
but despite its increasingly cliched
usage in English however it's difficult
to underestimate the importance of karma
in Buddhist thought for example
according to Buddhist cosmology when a
new universe evolves in the vacuity of
space the entire process begins when a
faint wind starts to blow in a clockwise
direction becoming stronger and stronger
until the circle of water forms above it
which in turn comes to be surmounted by
a circle of earth an entire world system
eventually forms over the course of many
aeons and when it is complete it is
populated by beings that faint wind
which begins to blow is the wind of the
Karma of the beings who will be reborn
in that world in Buddhist theories of
gestation the semen of the father and
the ovum of the mother are merely the
physical base for the new life life is
the consciousness that arrived from a
previous rebirth to enter into the drop
of combined fluids that consciousness
carries with it all of the seeds of all
the actions done by that being over a
beginningless past and is it is a
specific set of Deeds and not the
genetic inheritance of the parents that
then ripen as the body and mind of the
fetus as the Buddha said beings are
tears of their actions not surprisingly
then karma is the subject of a vast
literature in Buddhism ranging from
edifying morality tales to technical
scholastic descriptions in these
edifying tales we learn for example that
a father can be his own son professor
Granoff translated a giant story about a
man who was murdered just as he was
ejaculating and his consciousness
entered the womb of the woman with whom
he was making love therefore making him
his own son in the scholastic
expositions we learned that karmic seeds
always ripen in accordance with their
cause that is that virtuous deeds always
result in happiness that sinful deeds
always result in suffering we learned
that because a single cause can have
many effects the store of karmic seeds
is always growing we learn that if a
deed is not done its result will not be
experienced that is every experience
that we have a pleasure and pain whether
physical or mental is the effect of a
past deed we learned that karmic seeds
never lose their potency no matter how
long ago the deed was done we learned
that is not that it is not only bodily
actions that produce future effects but
words and thoughts as well and we
learned that the nature of the effect is
determined to a large degree not by the
deed itself but by the intention that
motivates it in the Scholastic treatises
we learned that there are deeds whose
effects will be felt in this lifetime
there are deeds whose effects will only
be felt in the next lifetime and a third
type of deeds whose effects will not be
felt for two lifetimes or more thus a
person who grows rich by stealing from
others may live happily in this life but
will surely suffer in the future a
person who lives a virtuous life serving
others may undergo privation in this
life but will prosper at some point in
the future we learned that their deeds
that affect only the doer and their
deeds whose effects overflow to others
we learned that a single deed done in
the past serves as the primary cause for
an entire lifetime where the virtuous
deed leading to birth as a god or a
human a negative D leading to birth as
an animal ghost or denison of Hell
within this general division into the
virtuous and and the negative there are
detailed divisions and subdivisions
especially on the sinful side it's
explained that a single action it is
explained that in order for a single
action to serve as the cause for an
entire lifetime it must be what's termed
a complete action in which five can
dishes must be met thus for example if
you decide to murder someone and end up
only wounding him it is not a complete
action if you decide to murder one
person and end up accidentally murdering
someone else it's not a complete action
if you decide to murder someone and
commit the crime but have a change of
heart before your victim actually
expires it's not a complete action these
are all negative deeds surely but they
do not have the power to determine an
entire lifetime in the case of murder a
lifetime in hell instead so called
incomplete actions of virtue and sin
determine the conditions of a specific
lifetime such as physical appearance
health and the presence or absence of
affluence we learned that the weight of
a given deed depends upon a range of
factors perhaps most importantly the
being for or against whom the deed is
committed thus five deeds are known to
deliver their doer directly into hell in
the next lifetime regardless of what
virtues have accumulated in the past
those deeds are killing one's father
killing one's mother killing someone
who's achieved Nirvana wounding the
Buddha and lastly a deed that to our
eyes seems much less grave causing
dissent in the monastic assembly we
learned that a single past deed can have
three types of effects a primary effect
an effect consistent with the cause and
an environmental effect thus in the case
of sexual misconduct the main effect
depending on the gravity of the deed
will be rebirth as an animal ghost or
hell being the effect consistent with
the cause is that when again reborn as a
human one will have an unfaithful spouse
you can find the environmental effect is
that your house will always be dirty we
learned that the moment of death is
particularly important in determining
the next life time according to
classical doctrine it is not the case as
is often imagined and is in fact
depicted in certain depictions of the
hell's that at the time of death good
deeds and bad deeds are weighed on a
scale
with the heavier weight of accumulated
deed determining determining whether the
next rebirth will be happy or sorrowful
instead a single complete action
performed in this life or any previous
lifetime comes to the fore at the moment
of death and serves as the primary cause
for the entire next lifetime thus the
state of mind at the time of death is
critical in Buddhism but the
recollection of a virtuous deed and an
attitude of calm said to bring about a
happy rebirth and the recollection of a
negative deed and an attitude of fear
and regret said to bring about rebirth
in the lower realms karma thus provides
the explanation for everything the
physical environment is the product of
the shared past karma of the beings who
inhabit it feelings of pleasure and pain
both physical and mental or the product
of past karma karma explains why some
are rich and some are poor why some are
healthy and some are sick why some live
long and some die young karma then is
part of the natural order but only one
part a poly tax called the Numa de pani
perhaps translated as the explanation of
laws of the explanation of the cosmic
order sets forth the various
constituents of the natural order the
first might be called the manifest order
that fire is hot that water is wet that
earth is solid that wind is motile that
each universe follows the same fourfold
sequence of creation abiding destruction
and vacuity that the three seasons three
seasons because we're talking about
India always follow in the same sequence
winter summer rainy season the second
element of the cosmic order might be
called literally the seed order or the
seed law the natural order as it
pertains to plants that a grain of rice
grows into a rice seedling that
sugarcane is sweet the third element is
of the cosmic order is karma itself
that virtuous deeds naturally result in
feelings of pleasure in the future and
non-virtuous deeds result in feelings of
pain it's noteworthy that morality is
placed here in the middle of the list of
five elements that costed the cosmic
quarter suggesting that the Victorian
enthusiasts of Buddhism were perhaps
justified in champion karma as a natural
law the fourth element of the cosmic
order is that of cipta consciousness
this order encompasses what we might
call Buddhist epistemology the ways in
which moments of consciousness are
produced in a causal sequence they're
the relation of consciousness to its
object and in the case of sense
experience the role of the sense organs
but we also find described here in the
cosmic order of consciousness
various paranormal paranormal powers the
divine eye that is the ability to see
things that are far away the divine ear
the ability to hear things that are
distant telepathy the knowledge of
others Minds the ability to remember to
remember ones past lives as well as all
manner of magical powers such as being
able to fly through the sky while seated
in the Lotus posture the ability to dive
into the earth to walk through walls to
touch the Sun and Moon with one's hands
the final element of the Buddhist cosmic
order is the order of the Dharma with
Dharma a famously untranslatable term
here meaning something like the order of
things this includes the general law of
cause and effect in both the physical
and moral realms the law of impermanence
that things come into existence abide
for a moment decay and then pass away
but this natural order also includes the
various portents that attend the birth
of a Buddha in his last lifetime the way
that a special radiance pervades the sky
the way that the earth trembles
so this list of the five elements of the
cosmic order represents in some reform
what might be termed traditional
Buddhist science what are its salient
features it's a natural philosophy but
unlike ancient Greek natural philosophy
it also includes ethics in Buddhism the
natural order extends into the moral
realm it described an agricultural order
in which everything operates with a
predictable regularity whether it's the
sequence of the seasons the growth of a
sort of the growth of a sprout from a
seed but it also describes the tremors
that that attend the birth of a Buddha
the Buddhist system then describes an
order that mixes without apparent
differentiation what we modern would
term the natural and the supernatural
indeed it does not make distinctions
between nature and the human the natural
world and human society are mutually
implicated in their very origins so now
we have some sense of the role of Karma
in the description of the world but the
Buddha did not simply describe the world
that is the cycle of birth and death
called samsara or the wandering he
described a path to escape from that
world the purpose of the Buddha's path
has classically described is to put an
end to rebirth and the sufferings that
inevitably attended again karma is the
key rebirth is caused by karma karma
deeds of body speech and mind is
motivated by desire and hatred desire
and hatred are caused by ignorance thus
if ignorance stops desire and hatred
become impossible without desire and
hatred there can be no karma without no
Karma there is no rebirth as I say
without no Karma Wow
it sound like Sarah Palin we can edit
that from the podcast sorry without
karma there is no Reaper and the wisdom
that puts an end to ignorance can be
cultivated to a sufficient strength that
and that only makes the creation of
future karma impossible but it
incinerates the seeds of all past
actions this is the essential point the
wisdom that puts an end to ignorance can
be cultivated to a sufficient strength
that it not only makes the creation
creation of future karma impossible but
it incinerates the seeds of all past
actions thus when the complete action
that caused this lifetime ends rebirth
does not occur again but what does this
have to do with Darwin's theory of
evolution it would seem that the
Buddhist doctrines of karma and rebirth
correlate poorly with the theory of
natural selection in which random
mutations of matter not mind occur
unconsciously over long periods of time
in such a way as to ensure the survival
of a species from one generation to the
next and indeed in his recent book the
universe and a single atom the current
Dalai Lama writes quote from the
Buddhist perspective the idea of these
mutations being purely random events is
deeply unsatisfying for a theory that
purports to explain the origin of life
end quote this is another way of saying
that natural selection is at odds with
the doctrine of karma and the reason is
that it is it is that odds can be traced
to the one domain in which the Buddhists
are strict
dualists and that is on the question of
the relation of mind and matter for it
is a fundamental tenant of Buddhist
philosophy that cause-and-effect must be
of the same substance or dravya in
sanskrit a seed is the same substance as
the sprout it produces a pot is the same
substance as the clay from which it is
produced
thus mind and matter of the closely
related in many ways are substantially
different such that mind can
be produced from matter as the Dalai
Lama states quote according to Buddhism
the consciousness and matter can and do
contribute to where the origination of
each other one can never become the
substantial cause of the other end quote
consciousness is the product of
consciousness mind comes from mind the
present moment of consciousness is the
product of a previous moment of
consciousness the consciousness of a
newborn infant is the product the
consciousness of the infant in the womb
the consciousness in the womb is the
product of the consciousness present at
the moment of conception the
consciousness present at the moment of
conception is the product of the
consciousness at the moment prior to
conception that moment of consciousness
can only come from a previous lifetime
this in a few sentences is the classical
what is proof for rebirth furthermore in
Buddhism rebirth and hence consciousness
have no beginning the Buddha is said to
have refused to answer questions about
origins and end points such concerns are
counted among 14 questions to which the
Buddha remained silent
he warned famously that refusing to
follow the religious path until one
understand the origin of the world is to
be like the man who refused to have a
poison arrow it's corrected from his
body until he knew whether the person
who shot the arrow was tall short or
medium height the great Harvard Pali
scholar of the 19th century Henry Clarke
Warren called these 14 the questions
that which tend not to edification the
Buddha described all such questions as
quote a jungle a wilderness a puppet
show arriving and a fetter and coupled
with misery ruin despair and agony this
places the Buddhist thinker in a
difficult position with regard to
investigations of the origin and nature
of consciousness but it's clear that in
Buddhism consciousness does not emerge
from
anything it simply has no beginning this
is not to say that change does not occur
over time but the change is one of
devolution according to the standard
cosmology the human race is in a process
of decline decline in height in
intelligence in virtue and lifespan
indeed the average human lifespan now
said to be 100 years will diminish over
the eons until it's only 10 years a
degenerate age of constant warfare among
third graders certainly the most
horrifying Armageddon foretold by any
religion but from the perspective of
evolutionary theory the crucial point is
that in Buddhism because mind and matter
are substantially different there is no
transition from the non-sentient to the
sentient and there cannot be the theory
of evolution explains how species mutate
through natural selection and thereby
survive the goal is the perpetuation of
the species and this happens randomly
without intention yet from the Buddhist
perspective the entire notion of a
species becomes problematic one crucial
consequence of the beginningless cycle
of rebirth is that each sentient being
has been a god a demigod a human an
animal a ghost every type of insect the
hell being many many times in the past
each being has been every species in a
certain sense there is only one species
the species of the sentient with
phenotypic variation occurring not as a
result of natural selection but as the
result of karma with that variation
changing radically and to the site of
all but the enlightened randomly from
lifetime to lifetime
but that randomness is only apparent
change occurs because of aspis of
specific karmic causes furthermore there
is no dispersion of the gene pool from
one generation to the next each new body
and the cycle of rebirth receives the
full inheritance of all the karma from
all the past lives of that particular an
individual continuum of consciousness
and left unimpeded that continuum of
consciousness will go on forever the
goal of the Buddhist path is to stop it
the words traditionally used to describe
this goal are cessation extinction
Nirvana extinction in nature is the
disappearance of a particular species
such that the reproduction of a
subsequent generation becomes impossible
this may occur through loss of habitat
and the inability to move to a new
habitat it may occur through predation
through inbreeding through the
introduction of non-native species
through pollution through disease all
species it seems will naturally become
extinct one day scientists have
determined that extinction occurs on
average after a period of about ten
million years the species that remain
today represent only 1/10 of 1% of the
species that have existed the other
99.9% or extinct sit still the survival
of the individual species through
natural selection remains the engine of
existence in Buddhism the extinction to
which the Buddha refers cannot occur
naturally it can only occur as a result
of conscious intervention here the
rhetoric of the tradition suggests that
the species of the sentient is not
endangered by pollution the species of
the sentian is preserved by pollution
pollution of course does not infect the
body it infects them
mind- mental states called the clashes
or afflictions in Buddhism disrupt
muddled and Confused the mind displacing
virtuous States and inducing present
agitation and future suffering the
impurity that the afflictions discharge
is not easily expunged and can cause
pain over many lifetimes and these
defilements are organic to the extent
that they are states of mind that occur
quite commonly we might even say
naturally desire anger pride doubt
jealousy lethargy excitement laziness
forgetfulness distraction permanent
separation from these states is the goal
of the Buddhist path the goal called
Nirvana is not the suppression of these
negative states of mind but their
eradication and eradication which at
least in the early tradition entails the
permanent extinction of mind and body an
extinction that occurs because the
causes of their reproduction have been
destroyed there can be no mind and body
because there is no Karma to cause them
there can be no Karma because there is
no desire or hatred and motivate deeds
there can be no desire and hatred
because ignorance the belief in self has
been destroyed among the many wisdoms of
the Buddha there was a famous pair the
knowledge that ignorant has been
destroyed and the knowledge that it will
never be produced again so there seems
to be a certain parallel between the
survival of the species and the
perpetuation of the cycle of rebirth as
long as sentient beings the gods the
demigods the humans the animals the
ghosts to hell beings who populate the
realms of samsara as long as they are
driven by ignorance they will continue
to feel desire and hatred they will
inevitably act on those feelings thereby
creating the Karma
that perpetuates continued rebirth
ignorance is identified as the
conception of self the sense that
there's something out that there is some
autonomous entity that is the owner of
mind and body that is the doer of Deeds
that enjoys pleasure and suffers pain
that is the referent of the first person
singular pronoun and this conception is
not just a concept over the course of
billions of lifetimes it has become so
ingrained as to be innate present not
only in humans but in all forms of
animal life as well from the fleet of
the elephant motivating their behavior
coloring even sense perception of the
world it sounds something like The
Selfish Gene but it is immaterial it is
consciousness driven to survive by
self-cherishing moving forward through
time and through bodies trying to live
forever
the Buddha's claim is that as deeply
ingrained as the sense of self may seem
it can be uprooted that by destroying
ignorance desire and hate become
impossible put an end to the deeds that
drive the cycle of rebirth without its
fuel the engine grinds to a halt and
thus Buddhist sutras talk about the time
when samsara is empty that point in the
future whether hypothetical or not when
there is no more rebirth and because the
world the physical universe is the also
the product of the karma of the beings
born there when there are no more beans
to be reborn the physical universe will
cease to exist no more nature red in
tooth and claw according to the theory
of evolution a species strives
relentlessly although unconsciously to
avoid extinction if it does not evolve
it will become extinct and even if it if
it does evolve it will become extinct
eventually
according to Buddhism the species of the
sentient will continue forever driven by
the engine of karma yet for Buddhism the
highest goal of the species a goal that
can only be conscious is to seek
extinction perhaps it is life Denine
after all as the Christian missionaries
have been saying for centuries as we
consider Buddhism the science more
generally we might also pause to compare
their epistemologies their theories of
knowledge in the scientific method at
least in its idealized form reality or
truth whatever those terms might mean in
a given case has not yet been discovered
hypothesis and experiment are employed
to arrive at a truth that is at that
time unknown or at least unverified that
truth can change and has changed many
times over the history of science but
the new truth sometimes were finding an
old truth sometimes completely replacing
it the image is one of augmentation and
revision moving toward an ever receding
horizon of omniscience a theory of
everything over the long and very
development of the Buddhist traditions
they remains a shared belief that the
nature of reality was discovered long
ago by the Buddha and before him by the
Buddha's of a distant past in the
history of our world there have been
four or seven or twenty five previous
Buddha's counting Shakyamuni
and that same reality has been
understood by all the Buddha's in its
entirety and in his fullness this
reality is represented not as something
that the Buddha was the first to
discover but that he rediscovered in a
famous metaphor the Buddha described a
traveler coming across an ancient city
at the end of a dimly visible path
through a great forest a once great city
now deserted
ruins the traveler informed the king who
restores the city to its former glory
the Buddha is that traveler discovering
the same path to enlightenment that the
buddhas of the past have found thus in
Buddhism the truth is something that is
found and then lost and then found again
this is why it is said that the next
Buddha does not appear in the world
until the teachings of the previous
Buddha have been completely forgotten
the next Buddha who will be called
Maitreya will not appear will only
appear when there are no more monks no
more monasteries or nuns no more courses
on Buddhism or people who call
themselves biologists like me no more
books about Buddhism Maitreya will not
appear until a Google search for the
word Buddhism yields the message your
search Buddhism did not match any
documents in other words as long as the
path to the City of reality remains
passable and the city itself remains
prosperous there is no reason for repair
but when the city falls into ruin and
the path is overgrown with oblivion then
the path must be cleared again and the
city restored this is what the Buddha's
do again and again over the Aeons there
is no new knowledge only the remembrance
of what has been forgotten so if we take
the doctrine of karma and the theory of
evolution as our test case perhaps
Buddhism is not compatible with science
but if Buddhism could somehow be made
compatible with science what would it
look like the standard cosmology of four
island continents surrounding a central
mountain the cosmology very much
incompatible with modern maps would have
to be abandoned perhaps it is
dispensable
but the demigods live on the slopes of
the mountain and the gods live on its
summit and in the heavens above the
ghosts inhabited realm 500 yogena is
beneath our southern continent another
500 yo gene is below the realm of the
ghosts is the first of eight hot hells
with the other seven hells
stacked beneath it thus the six realms
of beings would need to be reduced to
two humans and animals
this Buddhism would be a materialist
Buddhism one in which the dichotomy
between mind and matter so central to
all Buddhist thought in practice would
have to be abandoned mine would become
merely an epiphenomena of matter and if
mine does not precede matter nor persist
beyond it there could be no rebirth thus
the Buddha would not have perfected
himself over many millions of lifetimes
practicing infinite forms of ten virtues
giving ethics renunciation wisdom effort
patience truthfulness resolution love
and equanimity he would not have that
bump on his head
multicolored beams of light would not
read it radiates from his mouth when he
smiled his disciples would not rejoice
at being reborn at a time when a Buddha
appeared in the world the Buddha would
not predict the time and place in the
distant future when a lowly disciple
would become a Buddha indeed
the Buddha would be a man a man who sat
down under a tree and contemplated the
law of cause and effect and then spent
his life teaching others to live
ethically and understand that there is
no self at the end of his life he would
enter nirvana put another way he would
die for the scholar of Buddhism this is
obviously a bleaching of the Buddha a
fading of his aura for the Buddhists it
is a domestication of the Dharma making
it laukika something of the world rather
than Lakota something beyond the world
one might argue that my attempt to
understand your vana in light of
scientific views of extinction is simply
another attempt to salvage the doctrine
of a particular religion because it
somehow
sounds like a scientific category a
Christian just as easily could make the
same claim about extinction and paradise
as the poet sings this monkeys gone to
heaven but I draw a parallel not to make
it another claim for the compatibility
Buddhism in science my claim or at least
my suggestion is just the opposite
rather than seeing Buddhism as
compatible to evolution why not see it
as radically incompatible seeking
extinction rather than survival seeing
persistence only in impermanence
stressing intention / compulsion
consciousness over matter my suggestion
is that we allow the Buddha to remain
beyond the world completely at odds with
the world and with science
perhaps we should allow the Buddha to
remain a counterrevolutionary
compassionately teaching the noble path
that leads to the extinction of the
human species thank you
we have time questions and conversation
is usual and as usual I would remind you
imposing up questions please come to the
microphones
first thank you very much I I never
really thought of in spirit how one's
evolution as a Buddhist reminded me of
teh arts vision of evolving toward the
Godhead but pardon me for being a little
contrary in' when i when i look at some
of the progeny parameter literature much
of what you said i guess it comes from
nakiya buddhism and in the in the
project of parameter literature and in
the debates of the middle way school the
Guardian and later to in chandrakirti
they severely attack much of what you've
laid out and say that it's empty and of
any substance and so forth and this
doesn't necessarily lead to it to a
horrible result of immorality in fact
one of the one of the places that can
lead is to the other Buddhist school of
Maha mudra where mind and phenomena is
is experienced and it's called an
appearance as if it is there but under
analysis it's seen as empty and empty of
any substance or identity and so forth
and permanence and so on and it's a it's
kind of occurred to me since your talks
began that that perhaps cognitive
science kind of does to Buddhism a
little bit what the Guardian and
chandrakirti did and that the Buddhism
is still quite redeemable and effective
even on those terms it appears to me I'd
like to hear your ideas on that I wasn't
suggesting that Buddhism is not
redeemable or effective and I'm sorry
that you drew that conclusion I was
actually trying to make that very claim
and I'm not sure that anything I said
would be something that new Guardian
chandrakirti would reject I mean so this
was basic food is doctrine shared by all
four Indian schools the cognitive
science part is largely irrelevant here
since we're talking about natural
selection right so I'll talk about
cognitive science tomorrow but today I
actually didn't see any particular point
that was at odds with I'm thinking
particular about some of the ideas of
causality and in taking for example like
the way a sea grows to a sprout and so
forth that that both the Guardian and
chandrakirti's yeah empty of intrinsic
nature but that doesn't mean that seeds
don't grow from sprouts or sprouts don't
grow from seeds right so it's there's no
I mean the whole point of the garden is
that emptiness is what makes all these
things possible and the conventional
level of reality on that is not negated
at all by emptiness so basic causation
is there through all the Buddhist
schools and it just its ultimate nature
that's that's debated so as they as the
relative truth of the two truths right
but no the Buddha is also relative truth
right
enlightenment so relative truth right
butit it's irrelevant Ruth so it's not
it's being a relative truth there's
nothing bad right enlightenment relative
truth
we're the scientific Buddha be concerned
with Wall Street or would decide to the
given not care at all yeah boy
I think the Buddha scientific Buddha
would not be too concerned about Wall
Street I think he would have he would
have gotten out a lot a long time ago
this idea contrary radical country to
sign right really fascinating idea I'm
just wondering what the implications are
does it mean does it mean that around I
think you make a very convincing case
that the contrary but just natural
consequence of that argument would be
that reject science really be in the
world with so much science I mean well
the compatibility becomes a huge huge
problem but I think I haven't completely
thoughts that thought this through but I
think it's really more of trying to
maintain the radical critique of the
world that the Buddha seemed to have
offered and one lives in the world
doesn't mean that one stopped going to
the doctor taking medicine if he gets
sick I mean all that is still functional
that's causality but at the same time to
be able to somehow maintain a kind of a
deep suspicion of all that in ways that
then lead one to what Buddhists would
consider more exalted States and what
those are difficult to define but I I
see it more as a critique of the world
in which one continues to live yeah
I think I may be answering asking
something of the same question that Kui
Chia is asking but I want to ask it in
terms of comparing because we just had
the Terek Terry Eagleton give the Terry
lectures and he was trying to make the
argument against some other more radical
atheist publications that he whether he
I don't think he considered himself a
Christian or didn't say was but he felt
like that understood correctly by even
traditional Orthodox Christian doctrines
there was nothing fundamentally
incompatible about science and Christian
doctrine but it was because they're
they're really doing two very very
different things mm-hmm so are there are
there people who I know I the stuff that
I've heard about the scientific Buddha
in the popular press these are people
that are making but really does seem to
me incredibly naive arguments that
modern science and Buddhism are
commensurate mm-hmm they are completely
you know commensurate right
are there people doing a different kind
of argument that kind of takes a long
more the way that some people have
talked about Christianity and science or
Judaism in science which is to make kind
of a mythological argument that say well
a religious statement is not true in the
same way that is scientific it's a
mythological account but it may be true
in some other kind of way
I know there's other are there people
who say that you could deem ethology
Buddhist doctrine in a way that maybe a
lot of Buddhists would recognize but
there would be still legitimate and
therefore not incompatible with science
are there people making that kind of
argument I guess yeah but I mean that
essentially comes down to this material
as Buddhism I was describing at the end
in which they're just animals and humans
and there's no rebirth and and people
then have wanted to even system 19th
century but even more recently made the
claimable if you really look carefully
we can't tell whether the Buddha
believed in rebirth or not so maybe the
rebirth in just something in Indian lore
that was kind of incorporated but the
Buddha himself didn't really believe it
that's been
that arguments been made repeatedly for
more than a hundred years and I guess
that you wouldn't want to go that far
yeah that's that's a problem yeah so I
mean I think that the point I was trying
to make in the first two lectures is
that a great deal is lost when one gives
up these central elements and Buddhist
doctrine and as cuicci said the other
night what is it must remain it just
kind of an aesthetic that is something
beautiful in the museum and we don't
want to kind of you know take all its
color away we want to be able to enjoy
that but again it's something that one
looks at and what I'm trying to suggest
today is something a little bit more
even theological that is that there is a
way to interpret the Buddha's critique
of the world which is very much at odds
with science and and maybe that's the
way it should be that is that the Buddha
is saying that there's something
profoundly flawed about our existence
the whole point is to get out of it and
whether science describes it in one way
or another is largely irrelevant at that
level
I noticed that you have not talked about
the Bodhisattva mm-hmm
which is more or less which we say
fundamental to Mahayana Buddhism yeah
and it's with this that many of the many
of the questions that are related to
Buddhism have we have arisen because of
the Bodhisattva will you comment on this
please what questions could you just
give me an example of a question well in
there are some schools of Mahayana
Buddhism which treat everybody as a
bodhisattva one who is ready to enter
paradise right nirvana but who refuses
to do so because they are waiting for
another and yet this doesn't seem to be
part of your picture at least as you
have outlined it today okay sure how
does this relate to Karma well it's very
much part of the picture so the
Bodhisattva whether we're talking about
the you know the early nakiya tradition
or the Mahayana is a person who makes
the vow to liberate all beings from
suffering and and does not become an our
hot that is did not enter the the easy
Nirvana and and instead becomes a Buddha
you know in order to lead others to that
same your vana so it's completely
consistent with what I was talking about
it's just it's going to take a very long
time and the question is so there's
actually a long debate in Buddhism
whether some SAR will ever be emptied
and some people say that it will some
say that it won't but there's no
question whatsoever that is the the goal
of the Bodhisattva to lead all beings in
the universe to Nirvana and when and
whether the Bodhisattva is the first one
who goes to the door the last one
somebody turns out the lights and that's
it so that's the end of the universe at
least hypothetically speaking and so the
Bodhisattva ideal is completely
consistent with this view that the
ultimate purpose is to get everybody out
of samsara and into Nirvana whatever
that means
you focus your discussion about
evolution in terms of survival right you
had this wonderfully wonderfully
constructed contrast between extinction
and survival when I think about the
jambs who talk about themselves as being
scientific
it's not about survival really it's
about progression it's about the
development of complex life systems from
simple organisms so I was wondering if
you would tell us more about those
people who thought Buddhism was
compatible with evolution where did they
see they saw it as a form of spiritual
evolution it's basically theosophy that
is that they want to say that all beings
are evolving to the state of perfection
and that darwin simply was was was right
but he was incomplete and there's
something else going on spiritually that
everybody then goes on to Buddhahood and
it was it was much more as kind of a
slightly more upbeat version right yeah
clearly yes sir just a little while back
about the flawed beings flawed human
beings immediately I thought of
Christianity Catholic you know an
original sin and that kind of business
but yet like say Christian Catholic you
know there's redemption if you will in
heaven and maybe kind of extinction
extinction in God that the self in God I
haven't given a much thought but I
wondered what you have to say about that
parallels you know between what you said
about Buddhism there's a flawed or
nature of the human being and the
Christian kind of parallel yeah I'm out
of my element on the Christian side of
things but I think that you know what is
interesting about the Buddhist case when
we look at evolution is the long periods
of time right so in Christianity we just
have one lifetime and then you you know
go to heaven or hell whereas in Buddhism
the process is beginningless everybody's
been going through this cycle forever
and that will either end or not the
Buddhist claim of course is that that
flaw which is a fundamental ignorance
can be expunged and when that happens
then the cycle comes to an end there's
some question whether there are certain
beings who will never make it but that's
another question these people called the
accont ACCA's it's earlier about the
progression of science as we constantly
update our knowledge and if we look at
if you look at science as a constantly
evolving some would even call it
religion in the West I'm curious what
you think about you keep saying how is
Buddhism compatible with science I would
turn that on its head and ask what if we
don't quite have our evolution of
science yet and how is science
compatible with Buddhism what if we
haven't quite got out of evolution right
and we're now judging this based on
these current that's exactly the Dalai
Lama's point so the Dalai Lama as I
mentioned in the first lecture is
basically saying that there there are
some things in Buddhism that are just
wrong I like the flat world and science
is right about that but there are some
things in Buddhism especially the nature
of consciousness rebirth and karma which
are truths which science will eventually
discover and he's fully confident that
will happen so the fact so he's making
your point the fact that these things
have not yet been proven means nothing
because they will check you know I I'm a
little bit too low on the path to sort
of need to have much of an opinion on
that
I recall it in the first lecture I
believe you were bringing up the
question about whether whether Buddhism
is a science or religion and I'm
wondering if that's sort of a pointing
us toward the idea that there may be
religious elements in science as well
and that the perceived incompatibility
may be related to to those intersections
the the idea that for example that mind
emerges from matter that's really not
scientific there's really no evidence
for that the people who are really
serious about consciousness studies
refer to the neural correlates of
consciousness rather than the neural
causes of consciousness specifically to
respect the lack of evidence one way or
the other in that regard likewise on the
other hand seems like what happens in a
religion is you collect a certain amount
of insights and experiences and then you
construct a synthesis and you cram them
into that synthesis and the synthesis is
conditioned by your culture and your
time so as that culture and time passes
and we get new insights and so on then
then you bracket so that synthesis and I
I would guess that anybody in here who
is religious at one time or another
during the religious service has
bracketed some chunk or another which
which they understand where the history
of it comes from but they don't buy it
and they they realize it's symbolic or
metaphorical and that sort of thing so
in Buddhism the same thing the four
mountains and the I mean the four
continents in the mountain and so on and
so on
we bracket those who's we we who are
trying to get some truth out of Buddhism
as opposed to look at as an artifact a
glorious art
to be studied from the outside well
there are millions of Buddhists over
history who believed in those four
continents and believed in the hills and
haven't bracketed anything right so what
about them we who are trying to say that
science and Buddhism need not be
incompatible okay huh so so the idea
being that Buddhism is the most it seems
to be the most rigorously rationalistic
you know religion in terms of great
religion that we have that's a Victorian
conceit I would say but it seems like
what what makes it appear not not that
way is is attaching these past synthesis
to the to the insights that continue to
have validity so I mean so you're making
the claim that one can can remove the
cultural elements and something called
and the essence of Buddhism will be left
I mean so that's the question and that
has been said in the West that there are
elements of Buddhism that are merely
cultural and then there are elements
which are essential and the point is to
get rid of the cultural stuff because
that's just some baggage that came from
Asia and to keep the essential and I
have no idea how one makes that
distinction
none whatsoever you sort of your science
is struggling to do that all the time
science is struggling to separate its
previous hypotheses that were culturally
bound and so on from from the emerging
truth so it seems like the same process
and to say that we can't do that with
Buddhism it seems to me is to say well
we have to we have to stick with
spontaneous generation because you know
in science that's integral to the
culture at one time but who decides NSF
yeah I think the chief difference uh as
you explained it and you could have
underscored a little better if you take
the Darwinian view that phylogeny
recapitulates ontology and we notice in
the development of creatures the the
progression of evolutionary development
this can take this is incompatible with
the notion of karma in which you can
backtrack right let us say so long as
you admit that from our scientific
knowledge up to date there has been no
example of reversal or an evolutionary
reversal in in this real world okay
then of course you're talking about two
very different things
the real question is if you believe the
draw twin Ian notion then you can jump
into what Jung believed he said if we
can see the evolution the in the
recapitulation of evolutionary
development in the physical part of
ourselves
why isn't there also a kind of
intellectual evolution that's buried in
the archives of our mind some however
which would explain in a certain sense
where certain dominant principles arise
in different cultures for the thing sure
and it could be this aspect of it right
that I hope you talk about tomorrow in
modulating between you know the worlds
that matter and the worlds of mine good
point on retrogression I'll add that to
the book version with a footnote to you
yeah hi professor um
just a quick addendum - I think it's
professor in slurs point about the
changes that one might see that it's
going always forward but I might argue
for example with the idea that with like
dentistry that fluoride might have been
seen as this great you know leap forward
and good things but then it leads to
people eating a ton of candy and being
maybe less careful about their diet
which seems to go along with the idea of
samsara that kind of whatever good
running is that kind of equal bad thing
so what if there are these perhaps and I
don't like this term idea of kind of
regression of evolution so some type of
de-evolution what if a we have no idea
how to study that but be that those
adaptations are taking place due to some
quote-unquote negative aspect in the
environment and so again it has this
evening out effect of samsara mmm-hmm
what would you I like that okay all
right